that's what's happening that's what take  as much time off my  conspiracy oh she played this way  let's find e5  come knight a6 h6  castle d6  this is not great for black but i've had  this position before  many years ago okay  for many years for many years  uh  guys we've got 97. you're  so you're two points behind but you have  a streak  are you really so if you win this you  will be  yeah you will be  oh i should take care of something okay  all right focus not focus i will shut up  okay i didn't play this very well okay  go to f6  h5  knight g1 what is this all about  he wants some queen d1 or something  i don't think i think he had better  options  queen d3 let's  invade bringing all my guys to the party  now  21 okay  queen of three uh wins for me  okay now i'm just winning  don't resist don't waste my time  here we go  [Music]  just exchange this  take the pawn that's over